so you've never talked to these people
and this is a first thing out of their
mouth yes we're here to discuss tender
messages that have been sent to me I
feel like this is gonna be awkward she's
about to find out why I've been single
for six years
I'm sorry but you're about to enter a
world of hurt yeah this is real do you
like dragons because I'd be dragging my
cross your face hmm no you look good
enough to eat
I want to dip you in ranch and roll your
around and bake it [ __ ] I think that's
a cute idea for a date I wish you will
send notes
I hate these carbs no cuddling no
condoms no so I will need a hard copy of
a recent STD test
yes your butt is hot I like that look
mom are you down friend this is all
right person covered in black and
smoothed are standing in the middle of
the desert you look like a nurse but
only part-time and on your feet time
you're running a small drug operation
where you help get marijuana to elderly
folks I don't like that at all
fu the difference between a chickpea and
a garbanzo bean I've never had a
garbanzo being all over my face oh so he
said pee all of his eggs one of em mmm
you sit on my face I want actually a
turn-up word I can't be actually put
like yo that's no fun
[Music]
speechless it was completely different
than what I thought it was you think
like meeting somebody okay and you you
normally you see face-to-face hello how
are you doing
yeah the first thing is seeing somebody
is hey you want to I don't understand
how these people expect for somebody to
even comment back I suspect some of this
stuff works for some of them with some
people who know you want me to anymore I
won't be on to okay where I'll be enter
there for like a month
marched around the White House some guy
climbed up the fence and and shout out
to the crowd does anybody wanna and one
girl one so like I said it probably
works for some